all right we're here in san antonio with
our friends eli alex we've shot a lot of
fake guns in our videos
and we think we're decent but these guys
are pros
let's see if our nerdy gamer skills can
bring us up to the level of people who
do it for real
just wreck it so that's your standard
vlog
oh yeah a child could operate this
there's a bunch of us here so we're
gonna start immediately with an
elimination challenge all this is gonna
boil down to is who faces off against
eli in the final elimination game we're
gonna start with a simple speed and
accuracy challenge we're gonna have four
targets everyone's gonna go
so i've never actually shot pistols
before i shot a bunch of rifles back in
namm m16 ak-47 and an m1 rifle
up we're engaging the first
second target target for target this is
a shock timer it will allow the guys to
know when to start firing so we'll do
shooter ready
ready they'll reply shooters ready
wait for the beep
[Music]
dude i'm kind of nervous
one arm one arm one hand one and a half
one and a half arms
[Music]
annie hit all the targets
ready
[Music]
[Music]
it's just way faster run just like this
okay
we think we're doing all right let's
just see what we're going to be up
against in the finals here all right
1.88 that was going slow
here are the final times after the first
round it's nico with 2.75
sam with 2.78 clint with 2.80 myself
with 2.51
christian with 2.15
billy did not qualify unfortunately he
did not hit enough targets that means
that christian and i are going on to the
draw and fire around i'm a little
nervous i don't want to shoot myself in
the leg yeah we should go practice
jake just looks like a dad right
now
let this hand
go here and then you're punching out
with that as it comes out
nervous
and that whole extra element is like
i'm uh see if i can take out jake the
gun master
underdog right here
say relax
don't let jake in your head don't let
his incredible time get in your head
[Music]
and hitting a target is extremely
difficult flushing he look at that smile
what can i say
if you guys play basketball you've
played pig same idea he gets to call the
shot the distance and then he has to hit
that target and hit at the distance if
he misses it's my turn i'm just doing
left-handed off-hand shots just so he
will lose really fast so i think i'm
gonna do a couple cartwheels into shots
or like basketball
go with no on that one what gun do you
want to shoot this guy the sti 2011
neil okay the high guy hi guys second
target
[Music]
damn
i just gotta make a shot now
[Music]
[Applause]
you're
on the right side in the middle
[Applause]
[Music]
that's pi
i don't have any chance at all i need to
i need to go full dad mode
i have a daughter named eliza
my son's name is jake jr
hey kids
dad
this is absolutely a hillberry here's
the deal i'm at pi but i figure if i can
get one letter on him i call that up so
we're gonna do just quick draw for
comparison
and we're gonna see
point nine
[Music]
i have a daughter named
[Music]
uh so jake uh lost um but he didn't do
too bad
you know right for being like a nerd
you
you hit
the target really well thank you
the big thanks to you guys for bringing
us out here and let us pair it up here
at queen's gun club eli if you want to
check out any of your stuff what should
i go eli underscore double tap because i
chose a douchebag name apparently
alex underscores edgar is mine now
here's the part where we go and shoot a
bunch of guns for the outro montage
i feel alive
guys did you even hear that i'm trying
to listen
[Music]
i couldn't hear anything
well i don't think i'm as good as a shot
as i would have hoped but what can you
do maybe i'll face eli again one day but
anyway we're back at the studio now
we've been doing a lot of traveling and
we got regular videos coming out once
again so make sure you guys are
subscribed make sure you hit that
notification bell because the guillotine
is coming up don't worry we haven't
forgotten a lot of people have been
asking about it we also have a bunch of
other really cool videos it's all good